love it or hate it there's never been a
film
quite like space jam a new legacy set in
the warner brothers server verse
it's packed with references that will go
over the heads of younger viewers
these are the things only adults will
notice in space jam a new legacy
sure lebron james has his name above the
space jam sequels title
much like michael jordan did in the
original space jam but
also like that 1996 film the villain
team is composed of mutated versions of
basketball superstars
this time around rather than the
monstars we get the goon squad
this team includes both nba and wnba
star players
but with some significant upgrades okay
let's analyze the competition
clay thompson becomes wet fire a goon
who has aquakinesis
the ability to control water in
pyrokinesis
the ability to manipulate fire the
nature of the character is a reference
to the splash brothers a moniker given
to
thompson and stephen curry because of
their ability to splash the ball with
three-point
shots and a riff on the old bash
brothers nickname bestowed upon
80s baseball superstars jose canseco
and mark mcguire anthony davis is the
brow
a winged creature with a unibrow also
based on a real nickname
davis has gained notoriety not only for
his skills on the court
but for well his unibrow diana taurasi
appears as white mamba a snake-like
being
the character name is a reference to one
the late kobe bryant bestowed upon her
years ago
praising her skills on the court by
riffing off his own
black mamba moniker damien lillard
becomes kronos
perhaps the most powerful of the goon
squad he's basically an android who can
speed up and slow down time to his
liking
the character's inspiration comes from
dame time a phrase that has followed
lillard since he was 13
referring to his ability to stay calm
under pressure and seemingly control
time
as he casually blows past the
competition finally
wnba sparks forward neca ogumake
is the scary arachnika a spider-like
goon with
six arms there are a ton of jokes and
legacy about lebron's near-constant
movement from one basketball team to the
next
since his 2003 debut despite being a
four-time most valuable player
and 17-time all-star he has played for
the cleveland cavaliers the miami heat
the cleveland cavaliers again
and now the los angeles lakers who as
don cheadle's
algae rhythm jokes better not get too
used to him
bug's chosen nickname for king james is
cleveland
not only a reference to his ohio
upbringing but also the city that has
loved
and hated and loved and hated him as he
has come
and gone over the years the funny thing
is at one time lebron planned to use a
legacy announcement to break cleveland's
heart once again
in 2018 as the world waited to see where
the free agent would land next
a teaser trailer was prepared that
reportedly had the looney tunes
characters stealing sports memorabilia
with lebron retrieving the memorabilia
and then appearing in full lakers gear
it would have served the dual purpose of
teasing the film
and announcing james new home but was
ultimately scuttled at the last minute
there's a good chance your child may
have seen the original space jam
and if so there's also a good chance
they remember the name michael jordan
that would help with the funniest scene
of a new legacy
when sylvester the cat announces at
halftime that the lopsided score is okay
because he just found another basketball
great to join the team
none other than michael jordan after
watching the lower half of a mysterious
figure
enter the room to great anticipation the
reveal is that the tunes have
accidentally recruited
michael b jordan the actor to help out
he looks confused a lot of popcorn gets
tossed around and then he heads back to
his seat to watch the conclusion
of the game it's a funny joke but you
can already imagine
parents all over the world saying you
know from black panther the creed movies
um fantastic four oh well someday
they'll grow up and find it really funny
early in the film we flash back to ohio
in the 90s when a young lebron
learns the value of hard work on the
court and of not wasting his time
on video games it's a cruel lesson but
one with a basis in reality
in real life the now primitive looking
but beloved at the time game boy was
all the rage from its introduction in
1989
until the late 90s the game we see
lebron playing is 1990's bugs bunny
crazy castle
which featured the titular looney tunes
scampering up ladders and being sucked
through tunnels
mario style while grabbing carrots and
avoiding baddies
decades later perhaps basketball fans
can be thankful that lebron put away his
childish things
but still tossing a game boy in the
trash in the 90s
such behavior would have been viewed by
most kids as nothing short of a criminal
act
if you see legacy with a child don't be
surprised if they have lots of questions
about all the characters in the
background
as algae rhythm explains the crowd for
the big basketball game is made up of
half
everyday people sucked into the server
verse by lebron james social media
and half iconic warner brothers
characters who make up their own wb
universe the result is one of the
coolest things about the movie
if admittedly done before in movies and
tv shows like ready player one and south
park's imagination land trilogy
count chocula cinderella snarf from
thundercats the background of the final
act is populated by characters from the
wizard of oz
game of thrones and even the violent
drugs from a clockwork orange
if your kid catches the reference to the
nun from ken russell's
1971 trippy 17th century nightmare flick
the devils well consider us impressed
there are also lots of wb cartoon
characters in the background
of those basketball game scenes so kids
should have no problem identifying them
right think again it seems highly
unlikely that a kid in the year 2021
is going to geek out over the herculoids
but protoplasmic creatures
gloop and gleef from the 1967 series are
right there
cheering on the toon squad in multiple
scenes peter potamus can be seen
floating above the court in his magic
flying balloon
flanked by the likes of space ghost
jabber jaw the great gazoo
magilla gorilla captain caveman and
others that kids most likely won't
recognize unless they're allowed to
watch adult swim
if they're hip they might recognize rick
and morty
if they watch the 2020 animaniacs reboot
on hulu
they might be delighted to spot yakko
wacko and dodd
hanging around but if they don't
recognize the scooby doo gang and their
mystery machine
well it sounds like your family has some
cartoons to watch
one fun element of legacy is that bugs
and lebron must put together their team
by roaming the servers
finding looney tunes characters who
reside on planets themed around classic
wb movies
to an adult it's a fun detour to a kid
some explanation may be required the duo
visit a dc themed planet
where superman and other justice league
heroes are glimpsed as daffy duck and
porky pig are recruited
most kids one would think would
understand those references
after that however they enter the 2015
blockbuster
mad max fury road which earned a hard r
rating and most likely isn't in the
saturday morning rotation
for kids the recruitment team also
travels to a black and white casablanca
world where played against sam
takes on a whole new meaning although a
cartoon humphrey bogart appeared
alongside bugs
an 8-ball bunny the legendary actor
doesn't appear in this version
while seeing such prominent recognition
of the 1942 movie
is wonderful the scene might swore over
the heads of kids like lebron going for
a dunk
perhaps most enjoyable is a visit to a
matrix planet where granny and tweedy
have become a couple of bullet dodging
badasses
then there's the austin powers planet
where elmer fudd has become a mini-me of
dr evil
and poor sylvester has been shaven to
become the villain's new hairless pet
cat
as an adult you might be jazzed to spot
wood harris
aka avon barksdale from the wire playing
lebron's no-nonsense childhood coach
but chances are the children in your
life will be much more preoccupied
looking for taz other adult-friendly
cameos and legacy
include sarah silverman stifling her
famously foul mouth
temporarily to portray a duplicitous wb
executive
alongside silverman is recent oscar
nominee stephen young
as another eager exec lebron's wife is
played by star trek and walking dead
series vet
siniqua martin greene then there are the
basketball game announcers
sucked in via their phones and told that
unless the toon squad wins
they'll become stuck in the server-verse
forever the guy in the bow tie is
smooth-voiced sportscaster
ernie johnson and to his left is lil rel
howery a funny supporting actor perhaps
best known for get out
also worth mentioning is zendaya as the
new voice of lola bunny
and funnyman gabrielle iglesias
vocalizing speedy gonzales
adult and child fans of the classic
looney tunes cartoons alike will be
rewarded for their hours spent
before the boobtube as certain moments
in legacy recall classic shorts when
lebron
first encounters bugs bunny the wascali
wabbit
shoves the hunter's cap and a shotgun
onto the basketball star
insisting that he act out a scene lebron
goes through a few
physical transformations as he becomes a
cartoon
one resembling the early version of
elmer fudd seen in cartoons like 1942's
the wacky wabbit
bugs and lebron also keep tearing rabbit
season
and duck season signs off the tree
recreating one of the most iconic
cartoon sequences
ever committed to film the bugs and
daffy square off in 1951's
rabbit fire while lebron attempts to
explain his dilemma to bugs
his son dom has been kidnapped by algae
rhythm and he needs to recruit a
basketball team to get him back
bugs puts the basketball star through a
series of torturous cartoon moments
perhaps the most recognizable is the
barbershop sequence from 1950s the
rabbit of seville
with bugs shaving and spinning his
unwitting victim in a barber chair
lots of other classic looney tunes bits
are littered throughout the film from
marvin the martians
you've made me very angry to wiley
coyotes
backfiring acme products check out one
of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite summer blockbusters
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss
a single one